hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over
prophylactic moves which i think is one
of the most important concepts in chess
it's the idea that you anticipate your
opponent's threats and stop them from
executing
their plan if you've ever played a chess
game your opponent does something you
look at the board and say
i didn't even see that option there's an
opportunity for you to improve
in recognizing prophylactic moves in the
game
i also want to announce that we do have
a sponsor for this video
it's a website i've used myself in the
past it is decodechest.com they're an ai
based platform
that both analyzes positions as well as
your own chess games
and then gives you recommendations on
how you can improve
perfect fit if you're studying something
like prophylactic moosh trying to figure
out what are the immediate threats
and how can we actually stop them in the
game
we are first going to take a look at a
few examples in chess openings and then
we're going to look at some more
advanced variations
one of the most common chess openings is
the sicilian defense
and the most common variation in the
sicilian defense has a prophylactic move
so let's start their sicilian defense
with e4
c5 knight f3 pawn to d6 pawn d4
after the exchange in the center of the
board knight to c3 black plays the move
pawn to a6 it's a subtle move you've
probably seen it before this is the
neigh door of defense
a lot of people play this myself
included but if you think about chess
opening theory you're normally going to
be thinking about things around
controlling the center of the board
pushing your central pawns
up to limit the number of squares your
opponent can go to
developing your pieces getting kingside
safety developing those pieces to
control the center of the board
and then formulate a game plan from
there black's not really doing that with
pawn to a6
but it's a key part in the strategy for
black because it stops a lot of the
threats that white has you have the
knight here on c3 can't come to b5 this
b5 square is a critical square
in this defense this other knight can't
come to b5
and this bishop here on f1 can't come to
b5 so it stops a lot of the threats that
white
has and white's gonna have to come up
with a
another game plan now what's nice about
something like
the code chess is you can use this to
actually analyze this position
so if i run this position through the
code chess you can see
first it has the major threats now in a
chess opening you don't always see
immediate threats we're not too many
moves into the game
but i do still always like to look at
any position and see what the major
threats are f3 bishop to e3
not really going to be worried about
those too much but you can see it says
the best move is
a6 in this position and why is that
some of the reasons is because it
prevents the knight coming to b5 the
knight on the d
file coming to d5 and the bishop coming
to
b5 with check so as you're analyzing
your own games trying to figure out did
i miss anything
try to use this and see what moves are
preventing my opponent from doing
something and i'll start to open your
mind
into don't just come up with your own
strategy how do you stop your opponent
from doing what they're trying to do
here's another common
chess opening for whites you can see
already castled on the king side rook
here to e1 protecting the pawn
two minor pieces already involved into
the action while trying to figure out
the game
plan from here and one of those ways to
continue is
to look at prophylactic moves what are
blacks threats here
one of those threats is to get this
light square bishop involved into the
game you can see it's the only minor
piece that hasn't moved yet and where's
the best squares for that i don't
necessarily
think it's d7 or e6
it's not going to come here to f5 really
the best square for the bishop is going
to come down to
g4 pinning this knight down to the queen
and so white has the prophylactic move
of pawn to h3
that doesn't improve the central control
of
the board from white as it may seem but
really
this allows white to still hold on to
the knight which does in turn actually
hold on to the center of the board so
with these
it's these subtle moves that you need to
be thinking about we're going over chess
openings we'll go over some
some later uh examples as well
and as the previous example you can also
look at the code chess if you want
to plug in something like this example
you can see what are the major threats
in in this example
g4 bishop to g4 is something to think
about
that's what black is threatening and you
can see the best move that they
recommend
they're using the stockfish engine is
pawn to h3
you can see it prevents the bishop here
coming down to
g4 so it stops that square remember you
can analyze
entire games or if you just want to look
at positions you can do that as well
does a really good job of walking
through every single move
and what are the threats and how can you
prevent that
we can take the same ideas and apply
that to the middle game
as well it's white's move here and you
can see in this position that white has
a spatial advantage meaning
that their pieces are pushed up a little
bit higher and black's starting to run
out of room to move their pieces now
from black's standpoint the best way to
counter this
is start to exchange off some pieces and
really open
things up and that really takes away the
threats
that white has of putting too much
pressure and kind of
cramping the position for black so
that's what black's trying
to do but it's white's move and so white
has an opportunity to stop that
and if you start to look at what are
black's ideas here well really black
would like to blow up the center of the
board and maybe this pawn chain over
here
so e5 seems like a move but black's
not going to be doing that because white
has pawn takes here on e5
protected by the knight and the queen
but black also has the threat of pawn to
c5 this opens up for the light square
bishop
to attack both the knight here and just
control this long light square diagonal
and also just attacks these pawns on
the queen side of the board this pawn
here on c5 is
protected by the bishop the pawn and the
queen right here
that's a pretty good move and so white
can look at this
understand the threat that black has and
then stop that by playing the move
pawn to c5 this light square bishop now
is not really going to be going anywhere
this pawn chain is
very solid so this dark square bishop is
not going to be moving anywhere right
now
yes anytime you move you do leave some
space behind so this knight can come
to d5 but then after knight to e5 from
white i feel like white has a much
better setup here black is still cramped
maybe more cramped than before
white can easily get the light squared
bishop it's already attacking the h7
square can get the queen involved into
the game can easily maneuver this dark
square bishop over to the king side
a lot of threats that white has on this
board
while still keeping black at bay because
we recognize what that immediate threat
is
same thing as we looked at before if you
look at the code chest you can plug this
in and it shows you that exact same
thing what are the major threats from
black
well the major threat is that black
plays pawn to c5 and so what's a good
move from white
it is to play this pawn to c5 it
prevents them playing from pawn to c5
gives you some additional things as well
to
think about so this is this is how you
should be thinking about every position
whether it's in the opening whether it's
in the middle game
and then we'll now look at one in the
end game as well
the last example we're going to look at
is a prophylactic move in the end game
many times players have a dominant
position
and it all just crumbles because they're
always looking for
the best attack and they never really
stop to think
how can my opponent come back what is
the best move for them
and how should i stop them knowing that
if as long as i don't screw this up i'm
probably going to win
the game in this position it's white's
move
and white has a dominant position this
rook here on
a8 for black isn't doing anything
white has this rook here on c7 a great
square for
this rook here pretty much blocking this
king here on
the eighth rank here this queen on e3
doing a good job of not only protecting
the knight here
on f4 but also indirectly attacking this
pawn here on
h6 but why can get pretty greedy here
why could
try to gobble up more material let's say
they play rook
to b7 white was not able to
think about what is the immediate threat
that black has
and that is queen 2 a4 queen a4 attacks
both the knight here on
f4 which is being attacked by now the
queen and the rook here on f8
as well as attacks this rook here on
d1 there's also some
other ideas that if black really moves
this queen away
well now things get pretty tricky
because there's a discovered
attack here with the bishop attacking
the queen
and this is check as well so the queen
can move that would just be a huge
blunder
but thinking about where can my opponent
go if i move
is definitely important to think about
and when you factor all that in
then it comes down to okay i know my
opponent's looking to play
queen to a4 that's an immediate threat
here of attacking both the
rook here and the knight here and what
is
the best move for white to continue and
then as you analyze the position
more you realize that the move rook to
f1
is a really good defensive move
this pawn on f2 is
eventually going to be attacked by the
queen and the rook because you want to
get your knight involved maybe
knight takes here on g6 at some point
but you don't want to expose this pawn
here on f2
so this is a defensive move but it's a
prophylactic moves it
keeps you in a strong position and
doesn't really give up anything it
doesn't allow your opponent's immediate
threats
to really do anything and so last time
we'll come over to decode chess if you
look at that and you plug it in you can
see what are the immediate threats well
queen to a4
is the immediate threat that you need to
deal with and it kind of tells you
why what happens if they can play that
and it tells you what the best option is
f1 is really the preferred play in this
position
and it tells you why and if you're
thinking you know why don't i play some
other moves
it gives you some other alternatives and
explains why
f1 is better
so that is prophylactic moves hopefully
you can take some of this and apply it
to your own games always be thinking
about what your opponent is looking to
do
and how you can stop them from doing
that it's going to make you a much
better chess player
again if you haven't checked out
thecodechess.com i'll have a link in the
description below
you can sign up for free so not asking
you to go and
pay any money definitely go check it out
though see if you like it you can run
their software a couple times a day for
free you can definitely sign up for more
than that
if you want to but definitely check it
out thank you so much to the sponsors of
this video thank you to everyone for
watching the video hopefully you enjoyed
this chess strategy going over specific
tactics on how you should approach the
game
if there's other tactics or strategies
you want me to include in a future video
feel free to let me know
but thank you guys so much for watching
i'll see you in the next video